what up space fam goes in here from
anime out poor and I've recently caught
up to the Dragon Ball super manga so
today I want to share my thoughts on the
latest exciting developments in the
story I don't know when the Dragon Ball
super anime will return but at least we
have the manga to enjoy until it comes
back which it hopefully will now if
you're a fan of Dragon Ball and want to
keep these reviews coming let me know by
turning that like button blue like
Vegeta's hair if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future Dragon Ball videos keep in
mind there will obviously be manga
spoilers
since I'm covering the latest chapter
now without further ado let's jump into
it as we all hopefully know the villain
of this latest arc is Morro
aka planet eater Morro now that I'm
reading the script it turns out I
actually had a typo I had plant-eater
Amaro which is hilarious because it
sounds like a super villain from one
punch man but back to the seriousness
planet eater Morro is a powerful wizard
who's been around for well over ten
million years he can absorb power from
people or from entire planets thus he's
quite the force to be reckoned with
last chapter we got to see the fruit of
Goku straining with Maris remember Goku
can't just enter mastered ultra instinct
with the silver hair like he did with
jiren but he does manage to enter ultra
instinct sine level as we've pointed out
sine is a gateway and is unstable so
maintaining a consumes stamina quickly
in the end Goku lost against moral side
wasn't enough chapter 61 is called
Vegeta reborn and in it the Prince of
all Saiyans gets a chance to take down
morale keep in mind Goku and Vegeta got
to Train and Goku even got a downgraded
hyperbolic time chamber to boot which
gave him extra training time so now with
Vegeta's fight we get to see who made
more progress in regards to beating
Morro during that time period obviously
the title hints at a new more powerful
Regina
Regina's initial hit unmoral seem to
have no effect best wife who Android 18
even says that majeeda talked a big game
but clearly couldn't back it up Morel
give some credit saying he's definitely
more powerful than before but he's still
no contender despite all these doubts
the Prince of Sands remains unfazed and
keeps going piccolo also emphasizes how
much Vegeta has grown saying he barely
recognizes him
in a comment like that about adieu
who was already clearly strong AF is
music to the ears of every Vegeta fan
out there I really liked the approach
taken and super to keep Regina always
around Goku's level so they push each
other it's one of the best rivalries in
anime no doubt and I hope to see it
going on for a long time to come
still though piccolo says something very
unshown it he says that Mauro is too
powerful he's on a level that can't be
overcome by training alone not a very
plus ultra attitude but again Vegeta
isn't giving up because of such doubts
in fact if he and Goku had that attitude
to begin with how many times would the
world have been destroyed already
against previous villains it's the
belief that enough training can
eventually bridge any gap that has like
Goku Emma Jean achieved the crazy level
of power they've achieved up till now
and that attitude will always get them
and us further that an attitude like
Piccolo's which would usually lead to
giving up prematurely
Regina's boss mindset keeps him fighting
even while it seems like Mauro has the
upper hand
morale praises the Prince of Saiyans
more saying that Vegeta will make for
the finest meal yet something he didn't
say about Goku then just as some people
are thinking that Vegeta just can't
accept the feat he performs a
significant dodge and lands a solid hit
on Morel that dodge and counter-attack
turns the table on the fight suddenly
Vegeta has the upper hand the complete
ops that what happened - Goku where he
was getting weaker than Morel as the
fight went on finally Goku spots
Vegeta's new move and majeeda explains
to everyone that it's 4th spirit fishin
with each hit he is making more a weaker
Morel goes back to his old weaker self
and Vegeta explains that he liberated
the souls and life energy Mauro had
stolen with his hits he sends the energy
and souls back and they return to the
planets moral stolen from Goku further
explains that this technique tears apart
things that were combined through fusion
or absorption so we sort of have a new
move that could keep our guys from using
fusion in the future obviously because
of pride Vegeta always hated the idea of
fusing but now even if they have two or
everyone dies an opponent who can use
this move could render the overpowered
Vegeta or Gogeta
useless definitely a big game-changer
for
future and it's interesting to see these
kinds of different approaches to
fighting I love it that Vegeta can
one-up Goku like this but it's done in
an interesting non-obvious way rather
than just attaining the next level of
Super Saiyan before him Vegeta mastered
a technique that Goku hasn't even seen
used before interestingly enough but gia
even teases piccolo saying he could
extract the other namekians he fused
with ages ago but let's please not have
piccolo made even weaker we get some
classic Vegeta being prideful and trying
to flex on Goku he says that him and
Goku underwent the same training the
Vegeta is more talented he tells Goku
that victory is his this time and Goku
smiles like a good sport but jitta would
have definitely taken it harder if the
roles were reversed but again but Gina
lets things go to his head too quick
it's like he's begging for a reversal of
fortune when he talks smack like this
Vegeta continues to kick around more oh
and he shares his philosophy of fusion
and absorption again saying it never sat
well with him because they don't reflect
once inherent power he craves a fair
fight which is a nice thing to say but
it's also easy to say when you're
clearly the one winning currently we
find out that Vegeta managed to revive
some people including some namekians who
had their energy absorbed this is some
great redemption for Vegeta's characters
since he caused so much suffering for a
namekians before and he genuinely felt
sorry about it he can't change the past
but it's nice that he could help them
namekians this time and it's really a
powerful illustration of how much Vegeta
has evolved over the years in a great
exchange between piccolo and Goku
piccolo asks Goku if he expected Vegeta
to grow this much Goku says he didn't
expect him to learned a new move or get
this strong but that's not the only
thing that piccolo has in mind
he points out how much of Aegina has
grown as a person and that's a really
touching moment but Jesus character arc
has got to be my favorite in the entire
series now that I think about it it
might have been Gohan if Dragonball
stopped after the cell saga but with all
that's happened since it's gotta be
Vegeta piccolo even points out how the
guy who once came to invade earth is now
fighting to protect it and to atone for
the sins of this past but Judah is a
great example of how people can change
for the better and I think those
examples whether real or
are very important for us all to have
it's hilarious how piccolo ends up
saying to Goku that he's responsible for
the change in majeeda but Goku modestly
and honestly says I just wanted to fight
the strongest guys out there and both
are true
Goku's desire to fight strong opponents
combined with his good-heartedness has
positively influenced and saved many
throughout the years in contrast of
Aegina piccolo mentions how Goku didn't
change and that he doesn't need to and
that's a good point to change just for
the sake of change is not a good thing
someone who's on the right path should
stick to it rather than purposely turned
down the wrong path and that is the case
for Goku both piccolo and Goku himself
agreed that Vegeta surpassed Goku this
time but Goku having a winning mindset
like always doesn't let that bother him
in fact it fuels scent and he says he'll
surpass him again just watch that's
rivalry at its best right there and Jaco
also points out how weird it is that
Goku wants to keep training even with no
bad guys around
he thinks it's obsessive however that's
what gets Goku and Vegeta going they're
on the path to mastery becoming better
than they were yesterday besides as many
great philosophers have pointed out it
is during peace times that we should
prepare for war or else we won't be
ready when it comes it's these different
mindsets that Goku and Vegeta have along
with their work ethic that separate them
from so many others who've fallen by the
wayside over the years comparatively
speaking
but Gina smugness comes in again when he
asks Jocko if he should eliminate morale
or keep him alive again if you're
familiar with Dragon Ball you know that
such smugness especially on Vegeta's
part does not tend to be rewarded and so
there's definitely for shattering at
this point that this could blow up in
his face as Fujita is about to send Moro
to the afterlife he'll specifically
Mauro asks and if majeeda believes that
he's not going to hell interestingly
enough Regina says he's naturally bound
for hell Vegeta considers himself a
villain and he's been prepared to go to
hell for some time and Wow that's
actually very cool on the Jesus part not
gonna lie he's totally accepted going to
hell like it's no biggie and he still
wants to atone for his sins even if he's
bound for hell anyway he wants to help
others not for his own butt
fit but selflessly all this stuff really
makes Vegeta a great manly role model no
matter what happens to him he wants to
help people selflessly and I really
respect that about Vegeta not
surprisingly Morel hasn't given up he
doesn't plan on going to hell since
he'll be too busy ruling the galaxy for
eternity you can say a lot about this
old magic gold man but he's got ambition
you got to give him that morale points
out that he still has his magic he
escapes which was kind of predictable
here like a great man once said when you
got a shoot shoot don't talk and Vegeta
talked instead of trying to finish him
off as quickly as possible now to be
fair Morel might have escaped anyways
but I wanted to quote the good the bad
and the ugly moving on Morel goes back
to his men and lets us know that he had
a back-up plan in just in case which is
pretty smart on his part he's clearly
not blinded by his power or pride and he
does take precautions
a deadly trait in a super villain the
goat dude straight-up eats the copy dude
in a bizarre scene that looks like it's
straight out of JoJo's then morose ki
according to Goku is not only back to
normal it's bigger than ever but Gina
gets knocked out and resorts back to his
normal form Morel now looks like a
piccolo and cell cross with a goat but
it's a cool design ain't got a lie turns
out that 7/3 the copy dude copied
Morrow's magic combat abilities and so
on Morel created a backup within him but
not only that he gained seven threes
abilities he's stronger than ever and he
has an ability to copy the best moves of
the sands now and that is the end of the
chapter with the table's completely
turned once again now is the fact that
Magina didn't just wreck him upsetting
not really in my view yeah it felt a bit
fast because it was all one chapter but
I don't think anyone thought that Morel
would lose so quickly just cuz Morel one
that doesn't change the fact that Vegeta
one-up Goku in this chapter he did I'm
definitely not saying he surpassed
mastered ultra instinct Goku but Goku
can't even use that form right now and
compared to what Goku can do right now
and what Vegeta can do you gotta give it
to Vegeta Morel had to flee and become
more powerful or he would have lost he
didn't have to resort to that with Goku
so yeah
Regina lost ultimately but that does not
take away from the fact that everyone
including Goku said he surpassed him but
gia still may play a crucial part in
defeating morale so let's not be too
hasty and counting Vegeta out plus we
got some great Vegeta characterization
this arc so far and I think that that
might be building up the fact that
Regina will play a crucial role in
morals downfall it's just not gonna be
as easy as training showing up in
one-sidedly kicking his butt but in
Dragon Ball it almost never is anyways
let me know what you thought about this
chapter and any theories you have for
what's gonna happen next
I love reading those if you did enjoy
this review and want the Dragon Ball
super reviews to keep coming it's
important that you smash that like
button to let me know share this video
with any men of culture that you know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future Dragon Ball super reviews
lastly the YouTube ad rates have dropped
big time so the support we're getting
from our anime outpour patrons is very
appreciated a very special thank you
goes for patrons over on patreon WAP has
survived these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
think are the one tier patrons the ones
who stay atop all clans Steven grata
Aloha attempt the world stealers acquire
respect potato Jonathan King Brandon of
Isles Papa Smurf the school bus King
riser Emperor otaku Ricardo Martinez
Thomas Jones Kinmen Oh Michael Hyde and
Jaden the vector controller and our pro
hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing about a fan Jason
Wilson Kings algae's Anatole Kazansky
Angel Cruz
cricket XV Joel Stanton very Gucci
Alicia actor Jessica Kayla Fantine Okami
and water Bonnie parts Saudi art
Woolworth ooh and a aura Kraken or elles
and deadly Saint thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to
patreon.com/scishow anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime like and of course dank memes so
check out patreon calm and male poor
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same
benefits thanks again and until next
time see uh space cowboys
[Music]